[Aplausos]
[Música]
año 2020 todos los países del mundo van
a sufrir una enorme recesión por la
pandemia del nuevo sars coronavirus 2
todos no hay un club selecto de países
que en principio van a salir
beneficiados y todo apunta a que el
mayor ganador de esta pandemia va a ser
nada más y nada menos que vietnam
[Música]
ya lo sé la primera palabra que os viene
a la cabeza cuando oyes vietnam es
guerra la guerra de vietnam en los años
60 miles de jóvenes estadounidenses se
marcharon a este país con sus botas
militares y sus fusiles pero la historia
es muy irónica porque ahora 75 años
después de todo aquello los nietos de
aquellos jóvenes vuelven a vietnam
aunque esta vez van vestidos de corbata
y armados con sus tablets y sus
portátiles sí amigos de visual político
vietnam está de moda podríamos decir que
es la nueva china
de hecho muchas empresas que tenían
fábricas en china ya están moviendo
buena parte del negocio a vietnam todo
esto ya estaba pasando antes de el
coronavirus pero lo cierto es que la
pandemia ha acelerado esta tendencia y
no creáis que hablamos de empresas
pequeñas atentos
[Música]
samsung traslada parte de su producción
de smartphones a vietnam debido al
coronavirus y si buena parte de este
cambio se debe a que vietnam ha sido uno
de los países que mejor ha gestionado la
pandemia y si habéis oído bien aquí en
visual político os hemos contado el
ejemplo de países como corea del sur
taiwán o república checa seguramente muy
pocos habréis oído hablar de vietnam
como ejemplo de gestión de la pandemia
pero lo cierto es que lo han hecho lo
han hecho que da gusto hoy es que mira
hablamos de un país un país
relativamente pobre con más de 95
millones de habitantes y que comparte
fronteras con china pues bien cuántas
muertes diríais que han tenido
la respuesta es cero cero patatero tal
cual en el momento en el que hacemos
este vídeo vietnam no ha tenido ningún
fallecido por kobe 19 es más uno de los
vídeos que ha sacado el gobierno con
información de salud pública se ha hecho
viral y no es para menos no tenéis más
que echarle un vistazo
[Música]
por favor
pero toda esta historia va mucho más
allá de el coronavirus veréis vietnam
lleva décadas creciendo y atrayendo
empresas de hecho hay un dato muy
curioso vietnam es una dictadura
comunista la dictadura muy parecida a la
que tienen en china sin embargo la
sociedad vietnamita es la más partidaria
del libre mercado del mundo al menos eso
es lo que dice una encuesta que realizó
el pib research centre en 2015 y lo
cierto es que tiene bastante sentido
cada vez hay más empresas que se
establecen en vietnam fábricas de
muebles de ropa de zapatos para que os
hagáis una idea una de cada dos
zapatillas de adidas tiene la etiqueta
made in vietnam y todo esto es curioso
porque hace diez años la mitad de la
producción de adidas estaba en china el
cambio ha sido rapidísimo y ya sé lo que
me vais a decir muchos a ver fonseca no
te emociones tanto porque todo esto no
significa que sean buenas noticias todos
lo sabemos la industria textil no paga
buenos sueldos ahí está el caso de
bangladesh bangladesh es la meca de la
industria de la moda sin embargo llevan
décadas anclados en la pobreza y si
tenéis toda la razón la industria textil
es una industria de poco
valor añadido pero a diferencia de
bangladesh vietnam ya está empezando a
fabricar productos tecnológicos y los
productos tecnológicos sí que tienen
valor añadido y fabricarlos genera
sueldos mucho más altos y diréis made in
vietnam pero qué clase de tecnología se
fabrica en vietnam si yo nunca lo he
visto pues seguro que muchos ahora mismo
estaréis escuchando este vídeo gracias a
un producto made in vietnam de qué
producto estoy hablando pues de éste
apple anuncia que ha empezado a fabricar
algunos de sus spots en vietnam para que
os hagáis una idea en los últimos 10
años el pib de vietnam se ha duplicado y
este dinero se ha traducido en mejoras
reales para la vida de todos los
vietnamitas para que os hagáis una idea
a diferencia de los chinos el 97% de los
vietnamitas tienen cobertura sanitaria
es cierto que los sueldos todavía son
bajos pero también es cierto que hay
viviendas de protección oficial y toda
clase de programas para reducir la
pobreza
ciudades como chi minh city o hanoi se
están cubriendo de rascacielos pero los
barrios pobres tienen infraestructuras
mucho mejores que los de otros países
como bangladesh o la india así que la
pregunta es qué está pasando en vietnam
cómo es posible que nunca hayamos oído
hablar de este país cómo es posible que
un país que estuvo en guerra con eeuu si
hay integrado tan maravillosamente bien
en el mercado mundial y cómo es posible
que vayan a salir tan beneficiados del
coronavirus hoy vamos a responder a
estas preguntas pero antes vamos a ver
un poco de historia
what morning vietnam pocas guerras han
inspirado más películas y más canciones
que la guerra de vietnam todos hemos
visto 'apocalipsis now' y todos hemos
escuchado a los escriben y si no lo
habéis hecho no sé qué estáis haciendo
con vuestra vida honestamente os lo digo
sin embargo todo esto es la visión
estadounidense de la guerra lo que
seguro que no conocéis también es cómo
vivieron la guerra los del otro lado es
decir los vietnamitas y creedme es una
historia mucho más triste de lo que
parece sí es cierto
vietnam ganó la guerra pero el país
quedó completamente destruido
ah
se calcula que perdieron la vida entre
un millón y tres millones de vietnamitas
y a diferencia de la segunda guerra
mundial vietnam no tuvo ningún plan
marshall como os podéis imaginar eeuu no
les iban a ayudar a reconstruirse y la
unión soviética tenía cosas mucho más
importantes de las que preocuparse que
un país que es que ni siquiera sabían
dónde estaba en el mapa por si esto
fuera poco el gobierno de vietnam
tampoco era un ejemplo de gestión
responsable o chi ming había muerto
durante la guerra y sus sucesores hacían
que el mismísimo stalin pareciera un
político moderado neozelandés para que
os hagáis una idea en pocos años el
partido comunista vietnamita expropió
todas las tierras de cultivo y metió en
campos de reeducación a más de 250.000
survietnamitas
[Música]
pero aquí no termina la cosa muchos
pensaréis que todos los países
comunistas se llevaban bien verdad error
durante los años 80 vietnam y camboya
entraron en guerra
camboya que también tenía un gobierno
comunista estaba apoyada por china así
que china terminó atacando a vietnam en
otras palabras que si la guerra con eeuu
no era suficiente los vietnamitas
sufrieron dos guerras por el precio de
una y como os podéis imaginar en el año
1986 el país estaba hecho un auténtico
ecce-homo hambruna hiperinflación y
pobreza extrema y ahí es cuando el
partido comunista convocó un congreso y
al igual que pasó con china los
políticos más jóvenes le dijeron esto a
los más viejos
[Música]
hemos cometido errores debido al
infantilismo de izquierda y el idealismo
estos errores se han manifestado en
mantener el mecanismo de gestión
económica de centralización burocrática
round sin político comunista vietnamita
y así es como nació el programa de hoy
la gran reforma vietnamita básicamente
el doi moi fue algo así como la apertura
de china pero en esteroides a diferencia
de china vietnam no hizo zonas
económicas especiales directamente en 10
años cambiaron todo el país de arriba a
abajo para que os hagáis una idea en
1986 tener una empresa aunque fuera una
granja familiar pequeñita estaba
prohibido diez años más tarde
nike ya estaba abriendo sus primeras
fábricas en suelo vietnamita y ya sé lo
que estaréis pensando pues bien fonseca
muy bien esta historia ya la hemos visto
básicamente esto es lo que pasó en china
verdad que le hace especial a vietnam
pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
pero bajo en aranceles si tienes una
empresa y quieres abrir una fábrica
vietnam tiene dos ventajas imbatibles
respecto a china sueldos más bajos y
población más joven ya lo explicamos en
otros vídeos la política de hijo único
en china ha traído una sociedad muy
envejecida en vietnam hicieron lo
contrario el gobierno dio toda clase de
ayudas para que las familias tuvieran
muchos hijos y como consecuencia casi
todos los 10 a mitad se están en edad de
trabajar por otra parte los sueldos
chinos cada vez son más altos a día de
hoy un trabajador de shenzhen cobra un
sueldo equivalente a 1 de hungría por
poner un ejemplo
[Música]
y que suele pasar en estos casos pues
que china se especializa en tareas de
alto valor añadido
es decir que dejan de hacer juguetes y
productos textiles y empiezan a producir
sus propios smartphones sus propios
drones y sus propios coches eléctricos
cosas que requieren trabajadores con
estudios y los productos que requieren
trabajos más mecánicos se van a países
más pobres países como vietnam puesto
explica noticias como esta
el gigante de la fabricación de hilos
text song invertirá 500 millones de
dólares en vietnam habéis oído bien el
primer paso del desarrollo de vietnam
fue el de convertirse en la china de
china por el momento nada nuevo bajo el
sol nada que no hayamos visto en muchos
otros países sin embargo las cosas
cambiaron en el año 2018 concretamente
el 5 de julio de 2018
[Música]
la guerra comercial de trump con china
está oficialmente declarada en ese
momento es cuando trump empezó a poner
aranceles a los productos chinos china
respondió con más aranceles a productos
estadounidenses y entre medias muchas
empresas que tenían fábricas en suelo
chino empezaron a plantearse dónde nos
vamos ahora y la respuesta estaba más
que clara
vietnam está al lado de china de hecho
muchas empresas han podido burlar los
aranceles exportando las mercancías
desde vietnam
por ejemplo imaginad que sois un
productor de acero chinos y mandáis unas
vigas de acero directamente a eeuu
tenéis que pagar un arancel del 25% pero
hay una trampa podéis mandar esas vigas
al puerto de haiphong le ponéis la
etiqueta made in vietnam y tatán la
podéis mandar a los ángeles libres de
aranceles por supuesto esta práctica lo
que se conoce como el transit ping está
empezando a prohibirse pero muchos
exportadores han estado haciendo trampas
como esta hasta hace muy poco tiempo
[Aplausos]
[Música]
pero no sólo hablamos de trampas también
hay muchos negocios legítimos que están
empezando a ver a vietnam como su nueva
china y no ya no hablamos de fábricas de
zapatos sino de cosas mucho más jugosas
google traslada la producción de su
smartphone pixel de china a vietnam por
supuesto que esta no es la primera
fábrica de smartphones que se monta en
vietnam
nokia ya tenía fábricas desde hace años
pero este es sólo un ejemplo samsung
apple y muchas empresas más están
haciendo ya lo mismo incluso ya están
surgiendo marcas de móvil vietnamitas y
lo cierto es que vietnam también tiene
muchas ventajas políticas en cierto modo
podríamos decir que están en el mismo
lugar donde estaba china antes de que
llegara al xi jinping un país que cada
vez se abría más al mundo una dictadura
comunista pues sí pero una dictadura
donde casi todas las decisiones se toman
de forma colegiada
dicho de otra forma a día de hoy si
qingping es el líder indiscutible de
china tiene poder prácticamente
ilimitado en vietnam sin embargo tienen
un secretario general del partido
comunista un primer ministro una
presidenta del partido y una asamblea
comunista por supuesto que todos
pertenecen al mismo partido pero unos se
controlan a otros dicho de otra forma
que si sigue siendo una dictadura pero
mucho más suave que la de china y eso se
nota en pequeños detalles
por ejemplo los vietnamitas pueden ver
vídeos de youtube efectivamente muchos
de estos vídeos están censurados pero la
plataforma lo que viene siendo la
plataforma es totalmente legal es más
incluso a youtubers famosos vietnamitas
probablemente incluso este vídeo se
puede ver en vietnam y lo mismo pasa con
facebook google o cualquier otra empresa
de internet para que os hagáis una idea
mientras china es cada vez más
proteccionista vietnam está haciendo
cosas como estas
unión europea- vietnam el consejo da la
luz verde finalmente al acuerdo de libre
comercio
el acuerdo de libre comercio entre la
unión económica euroasiática vietnam
entra en efecto el 5 de octubre de 2016
pero todo esto es lo que estaba
ocurriendo antes de la pandemia sin
embargo en este vídeo ya hemos dicho que
íbamos a hablar de como vietnam es el
gran beneficiado por el coronavirus
verdad pues ahora mismo vamos a entender
por qué
[Música]
los ganadores del coronavirus ya lo
decíamos al principio por mucho que esté
creciendo vietnam sigue siendo un país
pobre si china tiene una renta per
cápita de 20.000 dólares y hernán está
en torno a los 8 mil seiscientos
[Aplausos]
sin embargo el gobierno ha conseguido
garantizar cobertura sanitaria el 97 por
ciento de la población a eso hay que
unirle que el gobierno pese a ser una
dictadura ha sido muy transparente con
todo lo que se refiere al coronavirus
desde el primer día lanzaron toda clase
de campañas para informar a los
ciudadanos porque tenían que llevar
mascarilla porque tenían que lavarse las
manos y porque tenían que evitar salir
de casa conclusión final pues a día de
hoy vietnam tiene 334 casos confirmados
de kobe 19 y cero muertes tal cual como
lo es todo esto teniendo en cuenta que
comparten frontera con china es digno de
un aplauso pero no sólo hablamos de
salud también hablamos de economía
una estrategia de china uno podría
mantener la cadena de valor más robusta
básicamente si algo hemos aprendido con
la pandemia es que no es bueno depender
de un único país que fabrique cosas y no
sólo hablamos de teléfonos móviles por
ejemplo el 95 por ciento del ibuprofeno
que se consume en eeuu viene de china
algo parecido pasa con otras cosas como
las mascarillas claro luego llega algo
como una pandemia y toda la producción
se va a freír churros no os preocupéis
porque todo esto lo vamos a explicar más
a fondo en otro vídeo que sacaremos
pronto pero quedaos con este concepto
china más 1 es decir vale tenemos un
proveedor en china pero vamos a tener
otro en otro país por si acaso las
empresas ya están tomando nota y los
gobiernos también
japón reserva 243 mil 500 millones de
yenes para ayudar a las empresas a sacar
la producción de china todo esto explica
que durante este año 2020 estamos viendo
tantas empresas moviendo parte de su
producción a vietnam desde google hasta
microsoft y si os dais cuenta ya no
estamos hablando de nike y adidas es
decir que ya no hablamos de talleres con
mano de obra barata cada vez estamos
viendo más empresas tecnológicas que
abren fábricas por esta zona y eso
significa trabajos mejor cualificados y
por tanto mejor pagados y ya sé lo que
estaréis pensando oh dios mío vietnam
debe ser el paraíso ahora todas esas
empresas que en su día se fueron a china
van a ir en manada a vietnam pues no por
supuesto que no de entrada
vietnam todavía tiene muchos problemas
pensadlo bien china lleva décadas siendo
la fábrica del mundo todo eso significa
que a día de hoy es muy fácil encontrar
trabajadores cualificados gente que ha
estudiado en universidades y que sabe
cómo producir bienes de alto valor
añadido además
china ya tiene unas infraestructuras de
lujo y proveedores de todo tipo a
vietnam le faltan muchos años para
llegar a ese nivel y por supuesto otros
países como tailandia también tienen
muchas posibilidades en otras palabras
que vietnam necesita invertir mucho más
en educación y en construir carreteras
además no hay que olvidar que todavía es
una dictadura con todo el riesgo
político que eso conlleva pero en estos
momentos si podemos decir que cuando
todo el mundo se está enfrentando a una
recesión gigantesca vietnam es una de
las pocas excepciones que va a seguir
creciendo
[Música]
así que ahora la pregunta es para
vosotros será esta la década de vietnam
cuánto tardaremos en ver a turistas
vietnamitas paseando por nuestras
ciudades puede vietnam llegar a ser una
democracia os seguirán los pasos de
china y llegará un nuevo sin pink
vietnamita que volverá a dar marcha
atrás a todas estas reformas podéis
dejarme vuestra respuesta en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribimos a visual
política y darle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras
actualizaciones si os ha gustado este
vídeo dadle a like y nos vemos en el
próximo un abrazo y hasta pronto
[Música]